Joe Rogan good friend of yours what does
he like Joe's going to open my funeral I
would like him to speak first cuz then
we got everyone's attention you can't
yeah Joe's going to open it I want tomg
to close it cuz he's when a fat guy
cries it's so emotional it's like it's
like that scene from Deliverance like
when you you're like wow this is real um
Joe's Joe's an amazing guy he's super
generous so like I was saying this to
you off air you got to be careful with
what you say around him cuz if you say
something like yeah I was looking at
smokers the other day the next day
there's a smoker at your house they
people that like good friends of mine
that are like hey man please H me up
with Rogan it'll change my career and
you're like that's not how it works if
he likes you he likes you and he finds
you and he's interested in you he'll
have you on his podcast other than that
you just got to play I mean just hang
out just be a regular human so when I
started playing for the Colts right yeah
all my friends want an autograph from
pton manic oh yeah so I had to start
forging pton
manic